[Music]
in a courtroom tense with anticipation
derek chauvin faced the judge to be
sentenced for the murder of george floyd
the court commits you to the custody of
the commissioner of corrections
for a period of 270 months that's 270
that is a 10-year addition to the
presumptive sentence of
150 months this is based on
your abuse of a position of trust and
authority
and also the particular cruelty shown to
george floyd before hearing his fate
chauvin had a chance to address the
court due to some
additional legal matters at hand i'm not
able to give a
full formal statement at this time
but very briefly though i
do want to give my condolences to the
floyd family
the foolish thing of our pain family
members made statements on how the case
has affected their lives
since the day last year when chauvin was
captured on videotape
kneeling on floyd's neck for more than
nine minutes ignoring his pleas for
error
i haven't had a real night sleep because
of the nightmares
i constantly have hearing my brother big
and plead for his life
over and over again floyd's
seven-year-old daughter gianna
spoke over video if you could say
anything to your daddy right now what
would it be
it would be our mission i love you
chauvin was found guilty of murder in
april since then the judge has
considered sentencing arguments from
both sides
as well as a victim impact statements as
an investigation into chauvin's past
chauvin's mother addressed the court and
her son directly
remember there is no stronger bond or
love than a mother's love
chauvin has been held in a maximum
security prison since his conviction
segregated from other inmates for
security reasons with good behavior
he will likely serve two thirds of his
sentence behind bars
and the rest on parole
chauvin is expected to appeal and still
faces federal
civil rights charges for floyd's death